adaptant la parole et à notre collègue
pierre charon pour le groupe l'est
républicain et pour deux minutes
monsieur charon oui monsieur le
président merci beaucoup s'en
tiendraient compte ma question s'adresse
à monsieur mise à l'intérieur qu'ils
aient eu raison de ne pas venir
monsieur le ministre voilà plusieurs
semaines car paris à nantes les français
assistent à lire et à des scènes
surréalistes de violences urbaines à
nantes
le centre ville est ainsi devenu un
rendez vous hebdomadaire pour les
casseurs avides d'y trouver des
boutiques à piller et je sais que le
président retailleau est exaspéré par
cette situation récurrente à paris 2000
31 mars la place de la république est
envahi par des individus s'intitulant
nuit debout mais qu'il fallait plutôt
appeler au lit le jour tag arrachage de
dalles pour faire pousser de l'herbe sur
une place récemment rénové à prix d'or
installation de temps de sauvages et de
baraquements saccages de commerces
musique à tue tête jusqu'à l'aube
incendies de voitures de police la place
de la république est devenue une
véritable jungle des occupations de
bâtiments publics ont lieu le théâtre de
l'odéon la comédie française et l'assaut
du lycée jean jaurès pas 150 migrants
organisée par l'extrême gauche vous
mobiliser beaucoup de forces de police
dont les ordres sont surtout ne pas
intervenir
pourtant il ya trois ans votre
prédécesseur était beaucoup plus prompte
à donner des ordres contre certaines
manifestations pacifiques
réunissant un million de personnes sans
aucune dégradation nuit debout bénéficie
de plus de clémence que les veilleurs
dont la seule arme était une bougie ce
laxisme sélectif déshonore l'autorité
républicaine
en voulant éviter à tout prix
l'injustice vous organisez la
désorganisation
comment se fait-il que l'on recule
devant les casseurs alors que les
terroristes ont été rapidement
neutralisé et que notre assemblée a
salué le ministre de l'intérieur à cet
égard monsieur le ministre quand
comptez-vous enfin de les descendre à la
police pour qu'elle puisse accomplir
sereinement sa mission le maintien de
l'ordre public
la parole est à jean marie le guen
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations
avec le parlement si le président en
2008 sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
pierre charon permettez moi de vous
donner un certain nombre d'informations
et je m'étonne quand tant que sénateur
de paris vous ne connaissiez pas ces
informations parce que depuis le début
du mouvement
nuit debout vous le savez 73 personnes
ont été interpellées et placées en garde
à vue
s'agissant des événements particuliers
que vous évoquez à savoir la nuit de
vendredi à samedi dernier c'est plus de
13 personnes qui ont été interpellées et
neuf ont été placées naf ont été placés
en contrôle judiciaire
neuf ont été placés en contrôle
judiciaire et donc seront poursuivis
avec la fermeté qui s'impose néanmoins
j'entends bien qu'un certain nombre
d'élus dont vous faites partie je crois
demande la suspension de la nuit de vous
au nom évidemment des mesures permise
par l'état d'urgence monsieur le
sénateur l'état d'urgence ne nous permet
pas de nous et nous ne souhaitons pas
d'ailleurs nous abstraire de l'état de
droit et vous n'êtes pas sans savoir
bien évidemment que le 19 février 2016
le conseil constitutionnel a rendu à
l'appui d'une question de prioritaire de
constitutionnalité un certain nombre
d'arrêts rappelant que les mesures
d'urgence doivent concilier d'une part
la prévention des atteintes à l'ordre
public et d'autre part le respect des
droits des libertés dont le droit
d'expression collective des idées des
opinions
il a en outre rappelé que le juge
administratif était chargé de s'assurer
que chacune de ces mesures serait adapté
nécessaire et proportionné proportionnée
à la finalité poursuivie voilà monsieur
le sénateur qui explique que l'état
appliquant strictement le droit n'a pas
l'intention de se mettre dans une
situation où il pourrait être condamné
car à ce moment là c'est l'état qui
serait effectivement affaibli
merci non non vous avez utilisé tout
votre temps trois secondes alors c'est
le temps ça y est monsieur le ministre
vous êtes comme tous vos collègues du
gouvernement
vous êtes comme les fraises divers vous
êtes hors sol bien